[Music]
buzzfeed is going to give my children a
hundred dollars to make me a meal
and no matter what it is i have to eat
it let's go tell them the surprise
my name is declan i'm 10 years old and i
love sports
my name is connor and i love
basketball my name is chicken and i bowl
and i love mommy my favorite food are
burgers my favorite food is pizza my
favorite
dinner is you guys have
one hour and a hundred dollars
to buy groceries and make your family
dinner
do you think you can do it i think i
would do a great job of that
[Music]
i think then going to the grocery store
it's hard oh
hi because if you go there's a lot of
options
do you think cooking dinner is easy or
hard
it's hot really hot because
you put in one second late on fire
and card please
[Music]
so is the challenge accepted yeah yes
yes
no so here are the rules you have
one hour total you have 15 minutes to
grocery shop
and 45 minutes to actually cook
you have 100 to spend no
more and no less let's go
so what do you guys want to get okay how
about
potato sauce so what is potato sauce
it's like sauce it's like regular sauce
i guess
uh you can get any kind of these sauces
what kind of food you guys want to do
right right
right bed okay okay let's get some eggs
okay we are at nine dollars
oh you have 91 to spend what are some
expensive things do you think mommy and
daddy buy
wine wine is expensive mommy does love
her wine
good point i don't think they have that
at this grocery store
confetti cake batter yummy and power
butter
[Applause]
frosting for that cake okay what is some
really expensive food like if you go to
a fancy restaurant what would you order
i don't mean what kind of
that pops meat steak is it
brownie okay i think ground beef you
guys have five minutes and 30 seconds
left
okay so what else is really expensive
uh i don't know if pretzels are
expensive maybe things better
i know what hot dog we gotta get some
fries
oh tuna is a very expensive
something like brownie and i don't need
that
okay maybe what do you guys want to do i
know
i really really love
cookies
one minute guys one minute
ooh cupcake mix you have
10 20 seconds 20 seconds
[Music]
what price are we at we are at 96 you
better hurry
that alarm's gonna go off
we're at 100 we're at 100. okay
awesome guys i think i hear the alarm
mommy is super excited to see
what you are making tegan do you think
you got healthy food
yeah you do what do you think mommy's
favorite is going to be
cake cookie dog the cookie dough sugar
i think mom will probably like our
surprise dish
oh the surprise dish are you confident
you guys can cook all these meals for
mommy
yep i've done a lot of cooking hey guys
just pick up the groceries that i
ordered online
yay yay
[Music]
i have fingers and frosting bread
pizza bites cookie dough bacon
and i have cupcakes french fries sausage
one apple lettuce
cupcake bladder brownie bladder
okay guys so it looks like you have all
your ingredients out since we've got a
lot of
baking ingredients we're going to start
with the one that needs to be
heated the fastest date times 31 to 34
minutes
and you only have 45 minutes you gotta
start hustling
they are
did you just lick my apple
okay teagan can you pick one box of cake
to make
mommy doesn't want to die today with all
the sugar
i need you to put them in rows okay
[Music]
i'll start making the legs are we done
tiana i could need your help
taking up the lettuce i am going to
shred it hey i want to know did everyone
wash their hands before they started
cooking mommy's food
no a little late but never but some hand
washing
is getting done i'm making the lettuce
what's the apple so we have to make the
brownies
no try to open it make sure you don't
get any children
if there's any parts of the shell tell
me
see it's gooey isn't it
[Music]
great why are you being really careful
because it spills
it'll be disgusting okay
yeah i think we're actually gonna make
fun ready next
we made the brownie the mix and the cake
mix we're gonna put those in
after the fries and the pizza rolls
looks like you're 12 minutes in the
water
half a cup of vegetables
don't crock it too hard
so this is actually turning out pretty
good but soon it will be done
okay so we need vegetable oil one cup of
water can you fill this up with water
perfectly
[Music]
my other favorite part is pouring
french fries pizza rolls brownies
and a cake is mommy eating anything
healthy today
yes today she is also eating a salad
great i'm curious to see what the tomato
sauce and the vodka sauce is being used
for
that's the surprise part hey mom can you
only take out the pizza bites
thank you okay what is tegan eating
sega who is trying to eat the cake mix
we are trying to tell her it will make
her sick okay the brownies and the cake
just went in declan how long are they
going in for 34 minutes
except we don't have 34 minutes we only
have 15. we're going for 15 minutes
great set the timer uh i think we're
gonna make
bacon you're going to make bacon with
the meatloaf mix
bacon stop eating that
what are you eating so i don't know
i've actually never learned how to cook
burgers okay so i'm going to
ask my mom how to kick it mommy would
say to cook them on the george foreman
grill
question dude would you like cheese on
your burger please did you buy me cheese
oh no guys so my mom's actually doing
something else right now
but i am actually going to trick her by
putting
some sardines in the salad
and vodka sauce in the other
don't tell her yeah what
french fries and
pizza bites they think mommy eats for
like
10 people instead of one of the cookies
on the plate
yeah okay you are close on time so i'd
get that puppy out
really quick i'm going to cut it in half
then put one of the other half on top of
the first half
cover it with frosting and do you think
they look cooked i don't think the
insides are as long as i don't have to
eat this i'm good
are you eating mommy's apple
yes but i think we did a great job
for someone who's ten six and four
hardest thing about cooking time
management
and how you're going to cook especially
in about an hour
because if you time it not great
it'll be all rusty and it'll be
all like burnt
apparently my kids do not think that i
eat very healthy
what do i try first it looks like they
made some kind of
i don't know like a vinaigrette for it
let's try it
it's not a vinaigrette vodka sauce
that's cool vodka sauce okay
apple looks delicious
it's not an apple it's cool tuna fish
it's not good but it's not terrible okay
hey burgers is there anything on the
burger you got buns
nope just buns and bread i wasn't sure
how it was going to come out declan
because i noticed on the ingredients you
named by regular meat
you brought meatloaf which means that
it's a mixed meat
but as a burger this is actually amazing
i would
absolutely eat this for dinner oh so
that's why when i cooked it it was
really red
mm-hmm it has brownie oh
okay i'm gonna eat some of the brownie
that is
cooked because i don't want to get sick
it's gooey it's delicious
now i'm trying to keep it it's delicious
come on over here thank you buzzfeed for
this challenge
[Music]
you